[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 143 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm ma Crandall and I'm here with my
colleague Melanie work hey Melanie hi
mark how you doing okay
okay we're not doing next anymore at
least for eight months at least for a
month exactly
so this week we have starin and Stewart
from the App Engine team joining us to
talk all about what's new in a thin jiin
yeah I should clarify we are still
sharing interviews that we captured
while we were at nextrip we're just not
at next anymore anyways yes that will be
a good episode of we know one of our
listeners actually has been asking for
when this is coming so here is the
episode as always we have our cool
things of the week and we're gonna end
with the question of the week which is a
question we came up with when we were
looking at our cool things of the week
actually which is what does it mean when
there's a recommendation that you should
update your image or find out what that
means maybe that just means change the
picture you're using change the
background wallpaper on your computer
maybe change the cat so cool things the
week yeah mark I know you found this
first one and you were so like
disappointed that I didn't know about it
so there's an article about the robot
dance party that we created at Next ok
so unfortunately it's not real robots
what when you first told me that I was
looking at it going wait just gonna have
like actual robots dancing around yeah
no so it was actually really cool
to correct if you happen to check out
the meteor and entertainment section if
you're at next there was a bunch of
animators who were there creating an
animated short of dancing robots and
they were working with somebody remotely
- out of LA yeah exactly so they had a
third person who was in LA and they were
doing it all at the same time right
they're all working together with remote
work and the people who were there and
while doing all the collaboration yeah
they were using virtual workstations to
be able to collaborate and using some of
the Google cloud tools with other tools
as well to basically animate create
these animated robots to do the dance
and with a little DJ as well it's time
to rock this place yo the video of what
they created is actually on the site
they spent three days on the [ __ ] floor
and remotely coordinating and animating
and using things like firestore and
rendered workers yep
you know I know rendering actual images
like animated images takes a significant
amount of time and what's kind of cool
is they were actually able to like a
sign multiple workers to render each
frame and we're talking I think it was
fifteen hundred frames is what they
listed or something around that so they
could just do it all in parallel because
it takes 13 to 30 minutes per frame to
render got it my favorite part is the
two dancers were Fred and Ginger
now they had a four-armed a robot called
DJ half K because was four arms
kubernetes has eight so it's a half K
but um pom yeah nice I liked it
Robo dance party well put the link in
the show notes another thing that we
wanted to mention for cool things of the
week is what's happening in bigquery we
had some stuff that was announced and
it's official that bigquery machine
learning is in beta so this is big
queries way of providing tools to do you
know future engineering modeling in
bigquery so you don't have to do any
moving of the data which is pretty great
yeah it's supposed to work natively in
sequel and this is really helpful for
those who are working with databases and
working with sequel they also have the
bigquery GIS which is in public alpha
and this is their geospatial information
system integrated with bigquery so it's
allowing you to basically use data to
support geospatial data types and
functions yep it also has a vis tool
that's on top of it to help you actually
apply this to maps directly just check
it out a couple other announcements in
here like clustering and data transfer
services so you can take a look and see
what's going on with bigquery query just
keeps getting awesome we're in awesomer
I know this whole idea of trying to a
couple tools where the data lives is a
smart move yeah I like it
cool up finally the nice security thing
so as you may have heard earlier this
year project 0 at Google disclosed some
security flaws in speculative execution
particularly spectre and meltdown as I'm
looking at the 14th of August intel
published details on a new set of
speculative execution vulnerabilities
called l1 TF for short the TLDR and I'm
not a security expert so I will read
this here is that Google compute engine
employs host isolation features which
ensures that an individual core is never
concurrently shared so one thing to note
about l1 TF is that what's a little
different from Spectre is that this
variant exploits speculative execution
by attacking the configuration of
processor level data structures rather
than the programs control flow so that's
where this is different that's where you
know it's it's referring to l1 it has to
do specific
with l1 cache and how that's being
handled and ways in which that can be
accessed and so Google is taking certain
steps has mitigations against l1 TF and
I know mark you were going to mention
some of those yeah so they've already
deployed mitigation to Google's
infrastructure including the
infrastructure that underpins Google
Cloud which basically prevents the
creation of the vulnerable page table
entries within the host OS so TL DR you
should be fine everything should be fine
we are well everything is on fire you
should be fine we are advocating as
we're usual like good standard stuff
make sure your images are up-to-date
make sure all your software is
up-to-date
what does that mean and for those who
are saying well what does that mean well
we're gonna talk about that after the
interview we are and now I think it's
time for us to go talk with starin and
Stuart let's go do it
alright well I'm very excited to have
yet another interview here on the next
show floor we have starin Giannini and
Stuart Riesling both product managers at
Google cloud how are you both doing
doing great how are you pretty good
awesome
you're here to tell us all about App
Engine and all the amazing new things
that are happening with App Engine
before we do that do you want to tell us
a little bit about both yourselves and
what you do here at Google
sounds good I'm a product manager on
Google cloud in the 7s team personally
I'm a node.js developer so that's why I
handled some node.js things regarding
app engine cool I am also a product
manager on App Engine
ster and I sit on the same team and I am
more of a Python guy that was a good one
so what's going on with App Engine so we
if you've listened any of the
announcements over the last couple of
days we have a lot of exciting new
things to announce for App Engine we're
making a big push on App Engine App
Engine has always been about a really
strong developer experience or security
built in the serverless model and we're
here to talk about that today Thanks
yeah so people who aren't familiar with
App Engine give us the pitch all right
App Engine is a fully managed civilized
application platform it was really
several as before it was cool so it's
case to zero you pay for what you use
and there is no several management we
entirely abstract the infrastructure
from you deployments are sourced based
so what you give
is your application source code then it
deploys fast there's a build pipeline
there's a built-in versioning and
traffic splitting details yeah so it's
often just been about you are a
developer who wants to write your code
you don't want to have to think about
setting up and wiring and the
complicated things around scaling app
engine is really supposed to give you
that simple developer experience plus
things like a pay per use billing model
and good scaling and we use Epogen for
our website yes but like serverless is
like totally 2018 like has an app engine
bateria longer than that
sure yeah app engines been around since
what 2008 we celebrated our ten-year
anniversary really 10 listen to or
entice talk two days ago
he called it the og serverless product
and I think that's exactly right it's
service before service was this cool
trendy buzzword so we can even say that
App Engine was here before Google cloud
what a thing right App Engine was the
platform before Google cloud platform
even existed it started a tiny initially
it had all those features built into App
Engine so datastore is actually an
originally an app engine feature and now
they are full standalone cloud products
so what's new with App Engine the world
has changed in 10 years right in a lot
of web frameworks have appeared and
originally App Engine was a little bit
forcing you to use a certain programming
model and all of that has changed now
App Engine is now what we say idiomatic
so in cloud nice we introduced what we
call the second-generation runtimes
in those generation runtimes really
allow you to use an idiomatic developer
experience so the idea is I'm a Python
developer I want to be able to write
Python code not necessarily app engine
code starin is an o developer starin
wants to write node code not necessarily
app engine code and so as part of that
we have these new runtimes three of them
right now to announce we have no date
that was actually previewed at Google
i/o we have Python 37 coming in the next
week or so
PHP 72 I'm actually not sure when this
airs it might be out by the time this
comes
and then we're working on some other
languages as well and the idea behind
all of these the unifying theme is that
they are idiomatic which means that you
write the language that you know you
don't think about using proprietary
stuff and actually probably a good
question as well right so you its
idiomatic what am i writing this stuff
for is it like websites like what am i
what am i what am i doing with this
stuff for sure yeah we see all kinds of
different use cases a lot of them are
web apps micro services anything that
needs scale either scaling up very fast
so you get a ton of traffic App Engine
scales automatically for you to meet
that need or you're not using it very
frequently it scales down to zero and so
in that case you're not paying for
anything during orange talk there was
the New York Times actually is a great
example where they have these crosswords
that are super popular right when they
come out everybody rushes online to try
and solve them well how do you provision
infrastructure for that you either don't
provision enough in which case you're
losing customers or you way over
provision in which case you're paying
for stuff that's not even getting used
and so App Engine is the perfect use
case for something like that suddenly
you get a lot of traffic it scales up
I'm always amazed by the the creativity
or focus of our customers like so many
people build their entire businesses on
top of App Engine many use cases are
about mobile backends or REST API s and
or even internal applications because
you just deploy your app and then you
don't have to worry about it it just
runs so that abstract away the
operations from you and to focus on your
business value and so you've also been a
big push on getting headless Chrome and
features like that built in why does
that matter for App Engine yeah so you
can you can easily build very small
services that are super dedicated to
doing one thing for example we put all
of the OS packages needed to run
headless Chrome on that engine so if you
want to run one service that just takes
a screenshot of a web page or generates
a PDF you can do that on that page and
then you don't have to worry about it it
just works so it meets needs all the way
from big web apps
down to you know developer tools
internal tools that you're building
yourself what are some examples that
seen that you've been pretty impressed
by in terms of how it's been applied
what we as we said we have some amazing
customers like I think the most famous
one is probably snapchat so that's
pretty amazing what they built on top of
App Engine going from very small company
to this massive scale using all platform
one of my favorites episode 26 no 23
with the if anyone plays video games
like I do a Humble Bundle that runs on
top of App Engine oh well they actually
specifically because they they do an
event that usual they used to do
especially an event based model where it
was like they have us events for cheap
games and so they get massive spikes and
having out the engine they said was
really great yeah humble bundles great
use case for that can Academy we are
very proud to to host them New York
Times as I mentioned you can go on the
website there's customers of all sizes
use App Engine have been using App
Engine for 10 years one of the things
that I hear from customers which is
pretty cool is you often get people who
say you know the thing I launched five
years ago I can still go use that today
it still exists today it still runs in
its current form they haven't been
paying for it that whole time but you
see even small things like my first
experience with App Engine was writing a
portfolio website I probably have my own
websites I deployed it was a game
website and 2011 I think it's still
running today it just hit the URL and
it's down that's pretty amazing
so sorry you said something earlier
which I thought was interesting we're
talking about the history of App Engine
and how datastore was once integrated
and then are now datastore has been
pulled out as a whole separate product
are there are other products that are
upcoming that are maybe being pulled out
of App Engine so that they can be used
in other contexts yeah we are graduating
some App Engine exclusive features into
cloud wide products so datastore is a
good example of that at next yesterday
we announced that the task queue feature
of App Engine is no standalone cloud
product it's called cloud tasks so task
queues are very useful when you want to
do things as synchronously so for
example you have to
do some computation it can take some
time and you don't want to delay the
response to your users you will create a
task in a queue cloud task will make
sure that this task is executed at least
once and most of the time exactly once
class schedule or another great example
App Engine has long had this built-in
cron functionality and again the stuff
it originated when these services and
concepts didn't really exist yet so
there's a service that you could use
previously to just say hey I want this
to run on this schedule now we're
exposing that as a first party cloud
services so you can make sure that any
arbitrary HTTP target gets accessed on a
certain schedule by the minute by the
hour by the day fully customizable and
these are features that you can now use
with App Engine you can use them with
compute engine you can use them with
anything that's that's awesome I'm I'm
not saying I've just created an app
engine app just to fire cron tasks so
whatever it may be I have you won't have
to do that in the future and we're gonna
have a bunch more announcements like
this in the next couple of months where
we're taking these services and making
them available to everybody any that you
can share right now no comment we can
talk about the recent things we launched
on that engine to show that we actually
are heavily investing into the platform
so earlier this year we completely
changed the auto scaling algorithm of
all of App Engine that was nobody
noticed it but it was a massive change
of for infrastructure and as a
consequence most of our customers got
better performances and lower cost so we
reduced the builds of our customers
without them having to do anything it's
one of the benefits of having a managed
platform is things like that things like
security these are things that you don't
have to think about which normally you
would have people dedicated to think
about these things and you'd spend a lot
of time trying to figure out how you can
optimize your infrastructure because
you're on App Engine that stuff is just
kind of handled for you another feature
that I personally like a lot is that so
App Engine you deploy your app good but
you probably want to put that up under
your custom domain and we provide a
one-click HTTP
for your Christian domain security
people must love you for that yes I was
just gonna talk a little bit more about
what it means to be idiomatic for us one
of the long-standing pieces of feedback
that we've gotten from customers is that
as I mentioned before it you know people
look at it and they go oh I have to do
these special things my app will only
work in this App Engine environment if I
design it for this I maybe already have
a workload that I want to move in or I
have something that I want to move out
to see how it might do in a different
environment because we are launching
these much more open open-source
experiences that means that you can use
any library framework dependency that
you want you don't have to use these
proprietary api's anymore all of these
things should just work the way you
expect them to work so I'm a node
developer I can get anything from NPM
even the binary modules they just walk
on App Engine same for Python
requirements that text put your
dependencies in there when you deploy it
all gets installed for you with the
correct versions that you've requested
we're even looking into other standards
like pip file because you know we love
Python we want to make sure the this is
the best place to run your Python
applications and we also made sure to
put some very useful OS packages in your
base image which is by the way a boon to
so you get a real boon to fooled with
some pretty useful packages like image
magic or ffmpeg and everything to run
headless Chrome as we mentioned seemed
very very happy about headless car it's
a nice use case right just run Chrome on
your server that's great so are you able
to talk about like why this change
happened like it seems like there's like
I think you use the term second
generation earliest Aaron yeah I think a
big part of it is customer feedback
we've heard from customers for a long
time that having to think about your
application in this specific model is an
impediment it's also part of the reason
why some customers choose things like
vm's instead because it gives them that
fully baked experience where they can
install whatever they want so lifting
these restrictions is really based on
customer feedback and to achieve that we
leverage a very big investment that
we've made into our infrastructure so
technically those second generation
runtimes are enabled by a new technical
stack
all based on G Weiser which is a
container runtime sandbox which is by
the way open source you can check it out
on github so all of those runtimes
new runtimes second-generation runtimes
are built using that new sandbox which
allows us to really allow this idiomatic
experience bringing any module you want
in that sandbox and just rewinding you
know when App Engine first came into
existence a lot of this stuff did not
even exist and so you know now we have
this new sandbox previously you had to
do a whole lot of things to the language
itself in order to make it run securely
on our data centers yeah we had to just
you're right I was gonna say does that
mean then that I I know some feedback
I've heard previously like sometimes we
aren't necessarily as fast as our users
would like I would say in updating
versions of like languages and stuff
like that is this gonna mean that we're
gonna get those updates a lot faster so
exactly this new technical stack will
allow us to first deliver new languages
to App Engine standout environments so
nodejs is the first example of a new
language that we introduced or the
standard environment and also will allow
us to first update for other existing
languages and keep updating them as the
releases comes in yeah as I've mentioned
multiple times everything should just
work out of the box if it doesn't you
know get in touch put our emails on the
website we want to hear your feedback so
if something doesn't work the way you
expect please let us know so everything
should work out of the box it should
work out of the box out of the box or
they call you will put your email so in
terms of working with App Engine what a
resources you would recommend sure so I
would foremost recommend our Docs pages
that's where we try to put all of the
getting started information you need
everything like that whereas previously
we have this very heavyweight doc set
that told you all about the specific
intricacies that you needed to know
since these were slightly different
environments it's much lighter now
because most of the stuff that you
actually need to know you can find
anywhere it's just if I know how to
write Python my Python should work if I
know how to write node my node should
work you don't really need to learn and
keep as much in your head anymore great
so for example if you're a node.js
developer you probably have
an existing app well without any
modification there is a very high
probability that we it will just walk if
you deploy it to App Engine so that
could be a good start to trying to port
an existing app and bring it to App
Engine with just one command G cloud at
deploy deploy second let me also add to
that there's a generous free tier you
can just deploy your app try it out see
how it works if it doesn't work no sweat
if you want something different no sweat
but we actually think you're gonna like
and stick to it
so as an interesting question I think I
think it's an Atrisco question that's
why I'm asking it for those people who
are currently on App Engine and have
apps running I was like do they need to
change their code or is it still fine or
what's the deal there before no date
there were no existing no date custom
that's true so this is mostly a Python
question there's still the Python to 7
environment for Python 37 yes if you're
just trying to migrate your app you're
gonna have to make some changes to it we
think those changes will make your
workloads more portable in the future
better in the future and more future
proof but as I said you know your
existing stuff will continue to run this
new runtime is really an incremental new
feature to which you can deploy now
idiomatic apps the way you would expect
in any other Ness so nothing's nothing's
breaking is just if you want to keep
pushing new stuff that's exactly right
beautiful so who's using this right now
are people using the new runtime have
you got any people who are trying this
out so we announced an the availability
of node.js on that bench and standard
environment at Google i/o earlier this
year so today we've seen some pretty
great adoption from the node community
and the new runtimes are just opening up
right now yeah so Python 37 PHP 72 those
are still in private alpha right now
we've got customers using them giving us
feedback every day expect those to go to
beta very soon or maybe already in beta
and by the way we are walking on goal 1
y 11 they're very good to hear that so I
know we've just finished the
announcements at next but what can
developers expect in the future for App
Engine so continued investment I think
App Engine is the thing that we're going
to continue investing in pretty heavily
obviously serverless as a broader
concept with cloud functions and App
Engine is what we think the future is
going to be and so we're looking at you
know more new runtimes a stayer and just
mentioned we're looking at graduating
more of these
services the way we have with cloud task
cloud scheduler we're also looking into
new features and how we can continue to
improve App Engine for example on the
networking side we're always trying to
tune our scaler to make it more
performant and so you're gonna see
basically more of the stuff that we've
been doing over the last few months
excellent and so what would you learn
developers to do like should they just
read the docs or like give it a try try
those new runtimes give us feedback we
want to approve App Engine with your
help
take take off quick starts I think we
even have from the cloud console if you
click app engine you can have in console
QuickStart
so without leaving the browser you can
deploy an app engine app all under the
fridge here so you know it will not cost
you anything to give it a try or even to
run one instance drink every day for
months so really give it a try give us
feedback we want to make it idiomatic
for you in your programming language and
where should they send that feedback
stewards are at google.com steer on the
google.com stearin on Twitter cool is
that I assume there's an app engine
Google group as well yeah we sit right
next to each other we're very close team
so if you send us feedback we'll make
sure that reaches the right people we
want to hear from you also questions
psyche overflow I try to look at it at
least once a week it's nice and
personable too frankly I mean it's nice
that that you want to be available for
that type of feedback that you want to
hear from the community for sure it's
the only way that we know that we're
doing the right things
agreed awesome so before we wrap up
today have we missed anything or is
there anything you want to make sure
that people go and see I think you both
gave presentations do you want to get
their name so that people can find the
recordings at the day to keynote we did
a preview of an exciting thing which is
several s containers so allowing you to
basically run any programming language
or any custom binary you might have
within a container in a surveillance way
so something that would scale to zero
with the same bidding model as flood
functions so that's quite extreme that
is exciting I did have somebody stop by
the booth rural area said you need to
talk about surveillance containers
yeah listen to these I did about that
well once that yeah once that's out
you'll have to come back on the podcast
and tell us all about it love to come
back yeah awesome thank well thank you
so much both of you for taking the time
today out of your busy schedules and
hanging out with us in the podcast booth
doing some our community
thank you against Aaron and Stuart for
coming on the show and talking to us
about App Engine and all the great
things that are going on with App Engine
yep it was really good I mean it's kind
of crazy that App Engine has been around
for so many years and they're still
doing stuff to it I know I mean cloud
started with that yeah yeah it's a long
life it's a long life but it keeps
updating itself
all right well mark question of the week
okay so you know we read in that article
I want to ask about how we as Google are
recommending that people make sure they
update their images yeah you want to
update your image what does that mean
and I think that boils down to sort of
where you're running your code I think
we should probably just talk about two
particular ones one is say if you're
running your code on something like GCE
instance like on a virtual machine or
whether you're running something inside
a container I think there's the two most
important ones if you're running it on
top of GCE it's basically probably
either Windows or Linux operating system
so if you're running say like Debian
which I'm most familiar with doing
things like apt-get upgrade or get full
upgrade to do kernel updates as well is
important to do on a regular basis
regardless and so when you do that make
sure you know if you're sitting behind a
load balancer which you probably are you
can then sort of roll those through
behind your scenes so that you don't
necessarily have to have any downtime or
anything like that which is super nice
so make sure those things are up-to-date
if you're running inside a container
very much the same thing so you may want
to update your base image make sure
you're running from the latest base core
operating system and if there are
particular packages that need to be
updated because of certain security
things make sure you get on top of those
as well
it's worth noting as well we do have the
automated container image security
scanning as well so make sure you check
that on a regular basis
that'll actually give you notifications
to let you know if there are any
particular security issues inside your
images as well which will link to CBA's
which then you can see exactly what's
causing that and then you can update all
your stuff and that kind of stuff too
and then two cents on this to when we
were reading about this in the article
one thing that they added stress is that
you want to take this into consideration
especially if you're running your own
multi-tenant services yeah all right
mark where you gonna be where am I gonna
be that is an excellent question so are
you who am I what am I even doing with
my life
driven me to come to this point
in the next hour two of the podcast
exactly so I'll be speaking at pax dev
in Seattle looking forward to that and
hanging out at PAX West as well it's
gonna be awesome all also speaking at
the game development section of Tokyo
next and be hanging out there as well so
I'll be in Tokyo for that which is I'm
really excited about said never been
before and then finally I'm heading to
strange loopholes up a little late
because meetings and I'm really sad
about that I love that conference and I
know but it'll be fine I'll be hanging
out with you Melanie it strange looking
a bunch of other Googlers as well so
which I'm also very excited about me too
right now Jen and Alden who our
colleagues will be there and speaking of
speaking yes I will be going to go too
deep owning Indaba
and Cape Town South Africa and I'm gonna
be doing some interviews there for the
podcast while you are at next yep and
then after that of course working both
through the Straits nope as Mark
mentioned and I'm really looking forward
to this because we will be hopefully
interviewing a friend of ours that I've
been trying to get on to the podcast for
a while so looking forward to that she's
the reason why we mark and I even know
each other anyways alright yes it's in
time and and it was at Strange Loop
so anyways alright well mark I think
that's it for us for this week
absolutely
thank you for joining me for yet another
week on the polka thank you and we'll
see you all next week
[Music]
you